haha okay and we're live welcome to the
weekly pool dang it Rob gave me no
notice at all Corian that is a love TV
little house who's currently got
Superman on Avengers and his set is ten
times better and that is Rob who I think
has Bob Marley behind him uh DC
explained image explained comics
explained everything is explained
Rob will explained how to use your
toilet paper if you really ask yes John
Lennon I don't know your heads huge it's
in the world of Marley thanks your eggs
in the way so today guys nothing of any
importance at all has happened so we've
decided that we're going to discuss the
chronological history of The Walking
Dead episodes starting with episode 1
season 1 all right so I can't believe
how it opened up yeah I know
Oh Frank Darabont directed it was what I
wanted I wanted to explain The Walking
Dead
ok yeah so there's the guy and they kill
zombies and then they kill more zombies
and then people turn into zombies and
then they kill those zombies they
eventually end up in a farm and they
waste a whole season at a farm and then
and I put a provision and then it's like
two whole seasons at the prison and then
and then it gets good again at season
five and they go fight zombies yep and
all this little salsa Marvel pops up and
says oh my god guys we're rereading
everything and they're like this is oh
my god no you're not they're like a real
thing we want to discuss today is how as
of May Marvel explained is going to
implode with an incursion and
everything's gonna be rebooted and he's
gonna take down all the videos and then
reboot them under the new continuity
muted Rob is not muted it's a good thing
I talked more than enough for the two of
us yeah we're gonna reboot we're gonna
be rebooting Marvel explained guys
because Marvel's our duty Rob is gonna
tell you all the stories of the furry
animals of the Marvel Universe so not
not squirrel girl squirrel girls
squirrels squirrel girl is a furry
reanima yeah no they're there they're
merging bow let's not let's not blow our
wad right off the bat let's let's
discuss this whole thing wait what do
you what are you gonna blow Sal cuz I'm
not blowing anything anyway if you
haven't watched the live event from
Marvel directly you know I'm talking I'm
got it up I'll tape it in here
yeah talk okay there goes I'll keep
going that's all I mean they can hear
him okay so Tom Brevoort and I think
axel Alonso were Midtown comics example
annex a store that I I frequent myself
acutely I didn't like him too too small
I will you have you gone upstairs that's
all this is actually a two locations now
but I don't like them either but that's
because they took money from me but you
know the point that I want to make about
that is they took a comic book and they
took my money and I don't like them for
that
no they sold my book I actually might
one of my books is actually available
through their website and in the store
and they sold out and then I asked my
check and they were like what check
you're like you sold my stuff why they
were like prove we did and I'm like
really we could do this you can't prove
that we had your product on our shelves
like 15 copies so they made like three
times 15 so I mean like dollars that
they owed you something yeah and that's
why I was like that's the end of that
like I'm gonna freak out over 40 I'm
just gonna I think your audience is just
100% rolling because not like he's muted
again and you haven't talked so I said
anything
yeah but alright let's get into I'm
gonna show them exactly so guys here I'm
gonna give you a demonstration of what
Marvel has announced is going to happen
so this is the six one six and this is
the Ultimate Universe and my face in the
middle is Marvel explained blown
not really not really um so yeah Rob
thought sometimes I do you want to go
first up you haven't said two words but
you gotta get into a man tell us that's
what you think happened because we have
a difference of opinion oh darn a know
how reliable I can because apparently my
audio keeps dropping out I don't know
why part of the carrot were all muted so
maybe he just needs to unmute his
YouTube video I think I think people are
screwing around in the chat I think
you're practicing for your role every
time I talk people die yes muted you are
how do you miss I'm looking right now my
audio doesn't matter what you're looking
at I can't hear you what's the sound
what is your opinion - what's gonna
happen well he plays in settings again
okay so they were talking about how like
because here's the problem okay they
already said like three different things
were happening they said that the they
the way they explained it was the last
one Kurt shall I see the problem
Rob you're much lower than us so if
someone has us reduced so they can hear
they can't hear you that's why when I
brought it all the way up I could hear
you oh really yeah that's your issue
creeping death he's not going in and out
not so low and he's dry eating drowned
out by everything else alright well
everybody else can hear him moving on
this is gonna be like the we need to
change this part we need to call it the
weekly pool and Rob's
inability to sort the audio out I'm
betting the weekly pool come and trawl
Rob for the first ten minutes of the
show the weekly poll we're 45 minutes
late we could hear when we did hear the
weakness well Rob doesn't know how to
turn his computer on the weekly full Rob
forgot to tell comicdrake we were doing
this today
all right so this they they said like
three different things were happening
the first thing they said was the last
incursion and if you're not familiar the
currents we don't have time to outing
persons yeah
dip there's three of them a comic story
and I did it like oh wait he didn't he
didn't do his ass good miner in death
fine way before robbed it like mine was
in like October you're sick of
incursians go check out back issues I'm
sitting is God after after going through
and reading incursions I am so sick of
watching world's crash into other worlds
I don't care like maybe if I gave a crap
about any of them it would be kind of
tense or interesting but I don't at all
like if it was like oh no it's the world
from such-and-such like something cool
if it oh no it's the world where the
exiles come from be like oh that's kind
of neat but it's just like oh no it's a
world where an alternate version of
Terrax is like taking over if the age of
Ultron is the house of M universe is
interesting but those are two of the
ones they've announced in yes coming up
I mean like during the 30 meters yeah
the Hickman has been Jules destroying
universe like nothing interesting had
been happening yeah the problem the
problem with the inversions overall
encouraged encourages before we go into
the secret wars is that it has not been
about any interesting universes the most
interesting one was the one that copied
the Justice League and that was only for
like one two issues to it yes that was
cool but no really quick Carla knows
says I really hope miles goes away in
the incursians carlin I think you're
going to be very unhappy with what
happens now this is of course just just
a speculation on our part but let's
let's get into it so like okay they said
the last incursion and if you're not
familiar the incursions watch more of
let's play in comic story if you person
is going to be the ultimate universe and
they already ruined it by saying that
no one's gonna be able to stop it so so
as a matter of fact maybe sit in the
livestream they like we ruin issue one
we're sorry well but you do get to see
them kind of like fight and try to
figure it out you get to watch everyone
like sweat balls for for eight hours in
the incursians and then blow up and then
we're going to get battleworld
now that's the second thing so the first
thing is 616 and ultimate kaboom second
thing battle world is formed battle now
if I got this right I mean it sounds
like basically when you go through and
curse you don't you don't actually get
destroyed
you go to battle room if that's the case
then the Illuminati are the greatest
villains of the moral unity are the kid
from the guy what was a show that's why
light zone where he sends everybody off
to the cornfield so he doesn't like the
world collide they go to battle world in
the 616 universe they fire a deaf cannon
at those planets and destroy crap and
anyone they don't blow up Namor stabs
with a trident oh no no in a more sense
than owes to go stab people with his
Trident the first time as I recall
against the Justice League Network stabs
the crap out of Batman yeah basically I
know that wasn't Batman I believe that
was like Knight man and his name was
wait it's bad character Superman in the
flash yeah so which by the way ends the
debate so that's the end of that
Avengers would be Justice League so it's
all had nothing to do with that so
battle world is going to be a patchwork
of universes that you liked from Marvel
and some of them happened and some of
them were alternate stories so like old
man Logan is a country in battle world
as is a version of house of M and a
version of the 90s x-men
and a version of spider-man that happens
to be married and have a kid it's really
weird I don't know what that means it
makes perfect but apparently they're all
going to fight it makes it makes perfect
sense like battle world consists of
stories that Marvel started but
realities they never finished like
realities had just kept going and going
on their own because remember like Age
of Apocalypse we found out in 2005 with
a 10 year anniversary
Age of Apocalypse is still going Civil
War I as an alternate reality where
Captain America's still fighting Tony
Stark the age of Ultron reality where
Wolverine had jumped and then killed
Hank pamorah that had led to that whole
universe with Morgan la Fey that reality
is still going like there's all these
realities that keep on keepin on so so
ok is battle world a physical cause
battle world apparently is going to be
the Marvel Universe during secret wars
the secret Wars the incursion takes
place between ultimate universe and 616
they both explode the ultimate universe
as we know it cease the era I'm sorry
the marvel universe as we know it ceases
to exist
yeah and instead what we get is battle
world which is almost like a multiple
universes a multiverse if you will of
different universes that that consists
in a one physical plane of existence
which is but kind of taking the idea of
battle world from the old 84 secret war
story
we're like the Beyonder took pieces of
different planets and made one planet
out of it only in this case it's just
many countries in one world and they're
all made of different realities are they
all going to fight or are these all
going to be books that we have to buy
there the way they explained it it's all
gonna be books because when if you were
by the live stream he has said if you're
a spider-man fan then this is going to
be your Spiderman book right you're an
x-men fan you'll be able to read all
these books
I think the way they're gonna do it is
you're gonna have battle world you're
gonna have some crossovers to a degree
but you're basically gonna have like
like this story here takes place in this
location so like if you all you care
about is spider-man then just read this
spider-man story if you care about age
of older age of apocalypse just read
this Age of Apocalypse story I don't
know
if there's actually any crossover here
and if this if that's where they take
and you have to buy each individual
story
that's stupid well I think I mean
they've already basically said um that
first off they're going to do books for
all of these so it is gonna be that way
right so York if you want to read
ultimate spider-man or if you want to
read a age of apocalypse by age of a
positive number one right and what they
said is that they're also not one-shots
it's not just like the original sin
stuff right you know just like oh we're
gonna jump over here they were jump over
here they said they are not one-shots
and that boy or 50% of the new 52 line
up and what they said also is that not
only they not want shots but a good
chunk of these are going to continue
after stupid Wars right now this sounds
to me and just throwing this out there
real quick I'm throwing the gauntlet
down that this is finally the crisis
that we've been assuming that Barbara
was gonna do and what they've been
talking about because they're gonna
smash ultimate and 6-1-6 together
they're gonna take the parts they like
and they're going to make their universe
the way they want it finally which I eat
first off for I'm gonna call one thing
we're gonna have a new Overeem so so six
one six will rain there right
he will never be revival or is it - oh
yeah they would help me revive cyclops
inadvertent no um old man a little bit
I'll be the new Wolverine get over old
man Logan bye-bye right but anyway okay
so the country's battleworld old man
Logan is one of the areas in battle so
here's what I'm thinking happen it sound
I was talking about this before Rob
picked up earlier so there was a big
leak between the two companies somebody
leads what they were doing because
convergence is the exact same damn thing
the most versus being basically
established and they're all going to
fight and I bet you money some of those
universes will get their own individual
books that you'll get to read not unlike
earth - what example and CC's probably
doing that and here's what I'm thinking
happened because and guys I'm not I'm
saying this particular moment
Marvel's taking a couple of DC ideas we
all know they just take from each other
all the free
from each other all the time here's your
nothin thinkin marble did marbles this
is my opinion and you guys can fight me
up into the Nellie one marble truck I
saw a new 52 they saw the game busted
numbers and they saw themselves could
squash that year so we all know where
that led to they did marble now they're
like well no it must be the fact that
they had new number once it must not be
the fact that they cleaned up the
continuity so they tried but yeah well
you know exactly but I mean that's what
everyone assumed they said they did and
so that's what got people to buy it
right so they tried marble now and it
did well and it did well again and it
did well again but now we have confusing
continuity issues and problems and
honestly I think cuz I read I've read
somebody's thoughts on this I'm pretty
sure this has something to do with the
movie situation because looking at this
way cuz for what I'm reading there's a
very strong is theory right now that
they're going to merge six one six in
ultimate universe into a single timeline
and they are going to get rid of
everyone that they don't have the rights
to in a movie so that they can do events
and not worry about these people anymore
oh yeah they've been talk about that for
a while okay here's that I've been
reading them they're gonna take x-men
Fantastic Four is spider-man and they're
each gonna get their own universes where
they're they're on their own world you
can do that and they can do what they
want with that so
freezy theory no it's it's not really a
theory like it's an actual idea like you
think they're gonna be like and it's
forever is what they're calling it like
the end is forever like a number for you
are ever and they're canceling the
Fantastic Four well they're canceling
the ps4 for a while I mean like and
that's what they're doing it this month
yeah like this think about this though
if they Ridge if they use this because
they're gonna merge those two timelines
and you know Bendis loves his ultimate
universe but the problem with the
alternate universe is almost everyone we
care about is died at this point yeah
all the carrots like care about is still
alive and you're gonna merge these two
universes you're gonna have an entire
continuity that is focused entirely
around whatever they want to do in the
movies and the people that they just
can't mess with anymore gone like yeah
because here's one of the problems I
think Martin's been running into
spider-man's enormous leap
there but they cannot get him back no
matter unless they're gonna throw just
Billy ain't like so so yeah sony Sony
knows they've got Marvel by the balls
right now and they're by having him over
by the balls they've got Disney but they
was like their own themselves by the
balls cuz I can't make a spider movie no
I agree but Disney doesn't want to pay
the money to get spider-man back well
they don't think they have to yeah yeah
so if you shuffle spider-man out of all
major storylines in the Marvel Universe
if you put it if you take him and treat
him like he has his own universe you can
even put the the cast of the regular
people in that universe honestly
building on that I think that based on
that big promo image of Secret Wars
which you can find on the Secret Wars
promo videos on all of our channels
the only spider-man that is in Secret
Wars is Miles Morales yep and I think
and this is just speculation and it's
literally based off of a 35 minute long
livestream from Tom Brevoort so take
that with a grain of salt but I think
that either you're gonna get Peter
Parker's gonna become the Barry Allen of
the of the original Marvel Universe
where he's gonna sacrifice himself and
die or move away or go away to his own
set for continuity or they're just gonna
simply do that and get rid of him and
Miles Morales will be the spider-man of
the proper Marvel Universe you know what
I want to see I want to see Wolverine
reappear in in battle world except I
wanted to be Wolverine from some strange
weird reality it's gone and I'm just
beer with Naga okay but he's not
Wolverine as we know him like he doesn't
have the adamantium claws doesn't even
have claws at all he just has like all
the powers of spider-man and like he's
really really hairy and he's got like
six eyes and he's called like tarantula
man and then like like he shows him
about a world and Marvel's like this is
our new spider-man could you imagine how
ridiculous to cover that comic would be
and this is why Rob does not write
comics so back to realistic
I'd be so pissed if our comic fan that
won't make a fool follow that you know
you know in the end what this looks like
I mean DC's convergence that they're
doing and they're doing it literally a
month in front of this yeah it's funny
it's beyond funny hey really quick just
building off of that convergence thing
who's doing it better so far Marvel oh
no I agree there because marble is
putting out like the premiere all the
covers are drawn by Alex where are
painted by Alex Ross that's a miniseries
that we know how many series they're
going to be in as a set and also feeling
it's been planned clearly convergences
DC's damage control
yeah like DC is trying to DC a like they
were like you know what it's like it's
like a it's like it's like a Republican
running in a in a red state and then
when he gets elected becoming an
independent and going like okay I know I
lied to you guys but I'm gonna give you
one term to make you not mad at me I
know what I'm doing it's DC going like
okay we're gonna alienate and throw it
all of our old fans by rebooting
everything and throwing out that and
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
and now that we've established that new
52 was successful and we've got all
these new readers hey wouldn't you like
to see all these other things you liked
things that we like to like Killing Joke
and you know all the other cool stories
that take place that we don't know if
they really happened or not well they
did and we're gonna align them with the
stuff you like so you're welcome for the
record in thinking cuz I've been reading
a lot of DC since they started the new
52 they've been kind of setting up
convergence sense as far back as the
Trinity war because at the end of the
Trinity of war we find out there's
multiple universes and dark sides going
through and killing them right and the
Trinity war was set up by the launch of
the new 52 so I don't think I don't
think it's just complete damage I mean
it's gonna be damage control for a lot
of continuity issues but I don't think
it's been it's it's like a let's just do
this to fix it I have a feeling the same
thing with the same thing with him to
get us back on track did the Secret Wars
they both have been planning this for
the last two years you can Marvel's been
playing in this the last two years oh
yeah and here's what here's what I think
they've been doing all of these Marvel
now number ones a lot of them start and
get stopped right yeah they're probably
testing the waters because you can
notice that all of these marble now
number ones are all new superheroes or
super hairs that they have the rights to
well isn't it great that they're all
spider-man replacements like all teenage
superheroes who have problems yep yeah
oh or the fact that we now have like 20
spider-man bits well honestly I think
it's spider-verse was two things one
then testing a Multiversity kind of
event and to Dan Slott getting to play
with all the Spider Men before they're
[ __ ] dead like before they go away
well here's the thing though they've
already announced a multitude of
spider-verse books that are in their own
cutter Glenn is going home and gonna
continue yes
she's not gonna be part of this battle
right it's not about a real thing she's
gonna be her own superhero on the side
um silk is gonna be your own book on the
side not a part of that old world
anymore that's a problem though because
I was under the impression Marvel said
that battle world was going to end all
these other cont'd it working there were
not yes any other universes there's just
only going to be battle world it's gonna
be one continuity and it's gonna be a
multitude of reality existing on a
single planet and it's only gonna be a
handful it's not gonna be every single
reality ever there are a lot of don't
have the names for and it could be those
I mean if you the Odyssey could play it
off like they're doing spider-verse
right now think about a spider verse has
a lot more spider-man than they're
actually showing us and if you could
easily do that with the worlds like they
could very easily like a spider Gwen can
just continue on no problem and in the
battle world her continuity just like
you just see over in the corner
spider-gwen swinging in oh that's for
real fighting this world you know or you
know they could do because they have
like they have a one of those flat maps
of the earth so you have like all of it
in one image they could do that and then
whenever they have like something they
want to do they just pull back and
there's the moon with its own bunch of
realities and you pull back a little
more and oh look there's Mars you know
reality you know it would be hilarious
if okay so just picture this all these
books that they want to launch just be
lord battleworld yeah we turns out like
spider-gwen after spider-verse
ends up in the House of M universe yes
oh she's there for this event you know
all right
like when she just doesn't go home her
universe isn't survived yeah or a spider
Punk whatever his name is I don't even
like the gutter Punk yeah I mean that's
not the first time they've toured around
with that I mean you got the Days of
Future present yeah Rachel's younger
just taken out of Days of Future past
and throwing the present I mean it's not
a very sad story
yeah there's years past or something
like that I can't remember faces
whatever yeah years of panel number
anyway um years of feature passes what
it is what I'm curious about and this is
this was ultimately when I think is I
think this is a stepping stone I don't
think this is a permanent thing I think
what Marvel is saying here is they're
gonna give us this battle world and then
after that they're gonna reboot
everything and here's why I say that you
gotta read between the lines when you
look at convergence this is what I love
about Jonathan's stuff he attacks like
many sexes to get rid of no like if you
if you look at incursions if you read
between the lines all right what's the
first thing that that rear it says at
the beginning of every reality dies
everything dies everything has a
beginning and everything has an end and
that he accepts that and that is where I
think it all takes place what mortals
told us here with the incursions is that
all the realities are gonna come to an
end
maybe they'll converge into one reality
but the entire concept of the Marvel
multiverse is that at one point it
started and then at one point it ended
and I think this is what's gonna happen
I think that ultimately you're gonna see
this battle world built up to a point
where all these realities are denied are
gonna and not just converge on this one
world they're gonna converge into each
other and so you're basically gonna have
the entire battle world
doesn't like be destroyed it's gonna
come to an end the entire Marvel
Universe as a whole including this
parental role is gonna end and
everything's gonna be rebooted oh my god
universe is gonna converge in a
convergence of world convergence of hey
man you know what would've been really
cool I dropped my called comics way to
take a take a line from one of the shows
i watch on the Internet
comics that's my theory here I think
that's what's gonna happen like because
I think Marvel's betting on the
faculties I think they're really kind of
throwing their eggs in one basket here
because one-third is a huge risk
this could be a total catastrophe like
this could be like a such decision
they've ever made they tried to do the
reboot with spider-man chapter one where
they were like all we're gonna do is
we're gonna make like Sandman and Green
Goblin related to each other and like
Doc Ock gets his arms during like it was
literally just Ultimate Universe a few
years too early and but they said it in
the regular 616 Marvel Universe and they
didn't make it an event they just said
like we're publishing this book called
spider-man chapter 1 and just explains
to you the new continuity that we're
gonna do and readers were like no like
legitimately like legitimately they got
the book they read into it no hey
someone got my reference to say a high
five casual you've got big picture and
the like spider-man readers and Marvel
readers were like don't do that don't do
see this up and the problem is an
infrared I mean so we've looked this up
we saw what the top-selling books were
yep in the end DC has been killing
Marvel and sales on comics so forth so
basically what happened was this but the
other day we were sitting round talking
about it and we all thought Marvel had
been winning at sales you know I looked
up the ax
top-selling books for each month and oh
like oh six yes it was like no even
before then we went back as far as the
90s we were like with you guys you guys
went back to 1998 yeah and we looked
back in over all the other happened
times when Marvel was winning I think
said I think some of their big events
really took over the events always
overtook it like civil war was the first
major one where they were like oh yeah
exactly every time there was an event
that was the winner but basically for
the most part it's always been DC books
that one on the books were Batman oh
yeah it was always a Batman a Superman
like it was always the big three of DC
or a Justice League right a DC of metric
old it wasn't like was mr. terrific it
wasn't even Green Lantern in flag no
Green Lantern only one during blackest
night blackest night took over that
whole year basically yeah so but yeah I
know we looked it up so so basically
what it comes down to is Marvel's
looking OD marbles crushing DC in movie
sales we know that we do know that DC's
crushing marble and cottage sales like
they both but the problem is Marvel
makes probably a lot more money than DC
does by crushing them in movie sales but
financial backing of Disney - yeah like
like the the publishing industry like
comic book publishing industry like
nobody should get into that if they want
to make money just like you don't want
to become a teacher if you want to
become a millionaire like it's it it
almost doesn't even make sense to make
comics at this point it is so
prohibitive Lee low-earning like
Snyder's got to publish like a hundred
freaking books in order to be not only
relevant but also like have money just
making comics and you can't do just that
like the publishing industry itself is
like so anemic it's like they're in like
Marvel could set the whole damn thing on
fire and it wouldn't really affect
Marvel's brand like they're just like I
don't know it feels like they could
literally do anything at this point and
I think they're finally wising up to it
I think it's just like a screw it will
crisis it up
it doesn't work out next year we'll just
redo it we'll just do it over again like
honestly like I I'm like this is I'm of
two minds of this like part of me is
like oh my god the whole thing is
changing or they're raising it to the
ground it's all over you know like the
end is nigh we cut into Sal one day in
the middle of it like we're doing the
podcast you just you saw spray
he's spray painting on his back wall
watch your coming but I really feel like
if it doesn't pan out if Marvel readers
are mother are our Marvel readers to the
end and Marvel readers are like no like
know what you know you know what I think
the biggest problem that new 52 proved
and marbles taken is now Koopa did you
proved honestly you could because we saw
the sales you could throw your
continuity against the wall and not even
give a crap about it and people will buy
the stupid books no matter what
well I I buy use to the new 52 books
right now and the continuity makes no
sense well the other thing is um new
readers exist we've been talking we've
been joking as comic book readers for
the last decade because for the last
decade or or more Marvel specifically
but DC as well have been tripping over
themselves trying to find those new
readers how we gonna get those new
readers how we get new readers in and
everyone all the cynics all the
comic-book reporters all the all the
outlets have been saying there aren't
any like new readers like stop trying to
sell to new readers you're just a lien
aiding the aging fan base that will
eventually die and then kill your
industry with them right like your new
readers are nobody your readers your
regulars are 45 like that cynical
attitude that cynical attitude has in
fact been proven wrong with the new 52
and I think Morrow was finally like all
right you know what there are new
readers and if we just tell them that
they can start here at 0 maybe they'll
come well you know what sorry I think
mother won't learn that with Marvel now
like like really no model now did suck
blood when you look at the sales of
Marvel
comics number ones magneto number one
Captain Marvel number one all-new
captain American of a whirly on issue
number three or four of all new Captain
America and those Toria stories are
selling pretty good so yeah like they're
not selling like better than any of the
top-selling books from a marketing
standpoint because I do know quite a bit
about a marketing crap I mean I but I'm
not a genius but from a marketing
standpoint the movies started this whole
movement the movie started interest back
in the comics but what Ironman came out
at everything we didn't see it influx
and comic sales because the movies are
great but everyone at the time knew
comics are so convoluted I you know
Ironman was great
you kept America's great but I'm not
gonna go read those books there's too
much history for me to read no new news
recently - yeah you think - to throw out
the idea of what if we just restarted
what if we just start the freak over and
just say we're done and we do it in a
brought in a ton of new readers and then
Marvel said what if we start with new
number ones and they saw themselves they
saw them selling King busters but they
still haven't rebooted that was the
problem
well here's the other thing Marvel
learned a different lesson cuz Marvel
also has helped destroy the industry by
doing this maneuver DC learned if they
reboot everything they'll bring in new
readers that's something that they do
every 20 years or every 10 years every
five years however long are we here at
the rate we're going here every year is
a reboot by the way is where it should
go and I don't mean reboots but I mean
like the way to go is no more shared
universe no or not no more assured
universe but no more shared continuity
graphic novels published graphic novels
self-contained stories make it like yes
that's not gonna work and they try not
they try that at early Golden Age you
didn't try that they've never tried no
they did that they did that during that
that was look that was the whole reason
why DC issue the crisis on Infinite
Earths because you had one writer here
who was writing Superman you had another
writer there who was writing Superman
you had another girl really they were
doing monthly they were doing weeklies
they were doing regular but I'm saying
graphic novels no more monthlies okay
okay so here's it I think they should do
not because they do graphic novels now
you can buy novels that are made just
really yeah but what I think they should
do is keep the shared continuity but
treat it like
it treat every year like a season every
September we start the next 12 issues of
everything and it's not it's not a five
year arc unless that one books doing it
but every every comic book company sits
down and goes what are you doing for the
next year okay yeah we're gonna tie the
done over here we're gonna do this
nobody planned past this year you're not
allowed to take spider-man and have them
go on a crazy adventure over here and
you're trying to take them over here no
spider-man is in New York he's gonna be
with the Avengers at this time no one
else watch freakin spider-man I mean
like they try to kind of do that back in
like the 80s and 90s and it was like a
mess
that's why maximum carnage had such
great guest stars like Deathlok and
Firestar and cloak-and-dagger because
the Fantastic were legitimately in
another story and the editors were like
you can't have the Fantastic Four why
because they're doing this right now
like they're literally over there at
this moment and it's like okay but see
now we've run into a slight situation I
mean III ran terrain up and down about
DC and how they tell their continuity at
us out of order like a great example a
great example the latest Green Lantern
he finally went back to earth in Green
Arrow
he's been teamed up with crew net over
the last three issues yeah and you find
out basically that it that time period
for Green Lantern it was during this
latest issue so that like so wait so I
thought you just read thronged recon to
do you had to window but now you made it
work just later in green like that's the
inherent problem that Marvel has
marvel's basically at a point where they
just have too many titles they have so
many titles and they have so many
writers they have so many artists so the
problem is maintaining continuity like
this that that I think has always been
the biggest struggle for Marvel
especially like from maybe the modern
age going forward the problem that you
have and I think that this was actually
the slump that we're in we're in between
ages of comics like you had the Golden
Age and you had the Silver Age any other
bronze and the other monitor and you had
the heroic age like we're between ages
at the moment I think and it's really
interesting because it just gets shorter
and shorter it used to be 20 years and
then it was 10 to 15 years and then it
was 10 years and now it's 5 years and so
on I think it's shorter and shorter and
shorter and shorter name like these in
the last 20 years they haven't named
like this is the modern age the last 20
years 25 years has been modern thing
we've kind of been in the heroic age for
a little while because like you had like
the Fantastic Four like the heroic age
is worth your time well they were call
it that's just the name of what they
were but that's that's I think that's
really some of the people have just like
taken it to be like okay this is what
we're referring to it as is like the
heroic age but nonetheless the fact
remains that we're edible I think we're
at a point now where the movies are
really the only thing keeping Marvel's
interest afloat with DC it's kind of
interest its kind of movies to a degree
but in truth the entire DC Universe I
would say rests on the shoulders of
Batman Superman and maybe a couple other
characters I mean it's basically Batman
Superman and Green Lantern at this point
I want to say it's Wonder Woman but
she's just more she she more has an
honorary title within TCC that actually
having any actual push back in DC okay I
think I think his name is Jim Chang I'm
not a hundred percent sure but the guy
who did the killing
the guy who did the artistry for for
Wonder Woman solo issue in 2012 I think
it was for a new 52 going forward but
the artist who was not any other okay
finishes doing it now I know this guy
was doing into the beginning like when
it was do you mean I was gonna say
azarello but he was writing it but um
but I the the story of one woman look
good the I guess the actual writing I
didn't care about like I didn't care
about the life of Wonder Woman like I
don't care about how she became Wonder
Woman like it doesn't matter to me
because she's never mattered to me
because I'm not a woman and her role in
DC Comics just doesn't relate to me I
mean it's I'm going to purposely
interrupt you right here Rob we need to
verify this right this second on the
weekly poll are you a woman
no no know what I mean you know what I
mean like people people will gravitate
to the characters they can relate to I
can't relate to Wonder Woman alright and
so because of that he's never run it's
really hard to make her and like I've
been trying I've never tried to get into
Wonder Woman books before but I don't
think it has anything to do with her
being a woman I think it just has to do
with the fact that like like Zarrella
wanted to do a story about like a modern
mythology and like it
all steeped in permissions and all these
different fantastic hair and I don't
give a crap but any of the things that
happened this current wonder what that's
going on it's not a very well written
story so I don't really care about that
either
and even then like there's more and more
stories that like where they tried to
make her relevant as opposed just trying
to tell a really damn good story and
that's why like whenever anybody tries
to say like oh Captain Marvel is them is
the Marvel equivalent of Wonder Woman
like fine because she's a female main
character I guess I was I used to think
that she Hulk was more like the female
equivalent or the Marvel equivalent of
Wonder Woman but like they've turned her
into something else but like Kelly su
Taconic tells stories about human beings
and not stories about like an empowered
woman who was going to like it doesn't
matter if she's a like DC's approach to
Wonder Woman has been wrong for the last
50 years okay and I actually thought
that men are in this but one of the
biggest problems Wonder Woman is they
created or just your creator and she was
there as a male fantasy that's all she
was that's why she got the last so to
begin wish you tied up villains they
always put them in like these bondage
poses a major that way I would argue
that they gave her the lasso because
like it is a less aggressive weapon it's
more of a defensive weapon than it is
like a sword you know yeah like well now
that's now that feminism has taken hold
and I don't mean feminism like Oh Ron I
just mean like equality and fairness for
everybody like now that like Wonder
Woman is they're trying to make her into
an icon and they're trying to make her
into like a relevant character that's on
par with Batman Superman and like Green
Lantern and other characters like that
like they're giving her like they're
trying to like steep her in her origins
like she's an amazonian she would have a
weapon like she'd have a sword and she
would be like Oh but the Amazonians I
know they don't use swords I'm just
saying yeah there's like pummel you but
you let me know when they when they crop
up I've seen some I've seen someone they
could pass for Amazonians here
yeah I thought I'd say this but and I'm
the one trying to bring it back let's go
back to marvel super dwarf okay okay
okay so here's you to keep bringing this
to DC so so here's the deal here's the
here's what's interesting I think about
this about this whole thing I like the
idea that Marvel's going with this I
like the idea they're saying well at the
very least it's gonna be one continuity
even if it's you know kind of shaky or
whatever but in my personal opinion I
think this is gonna be a total disaster
and here's why you're morally
backtracking of what you said before the
show I said I like the idea of it and I
think it's cool before the show you said
this is gonna make it easier streamline
get rid of it will it will but at the
same time it's gonna be a disaster and
here's why like they'll streamline it
but the problem is that Marvel has a
hard enough time keeping up with like
separate universes not even universes
that intertwine with one another just
separate universes all right let alone
having them cross over into each other
because at some point fans are gonna see
all these different realities is this
new on the same world and they're gonna
say I want to see them all fighting each
other I mean this called secret wars
secret Wars a story yeah well not in so
in the beginning I mean you know what is
what they were saying at the the lot of
in is they said like issue number one
will say hey guys here's battle world
and then the entry number two will be
like here's all the stuff that happens
it leaves up you know and and how the
battle world forms then issue number
three through eight will basically give
us the rundown on on like what goes on
in that battle world but the problem is
you can't have all these people converge
into one reality and then they're gonna
be on one planet but it doesn't look
like they're actually gonna like exist
with one another that is to say like
cross over into their realities we're
just gonna be like in little isolated
sections like that's that's how it looks
doesn't sound interesting to me in the
slightest yes that's what I'm saying if
that's the direction they go in it's
gonna be a catastrophe because basically
instead of saying like we have all these
different realities well now we have one
world that's composed of realities and
it's like okay whatever that's the same
damn thing you say it's calling
something else for the signal that's not
the different like you're insulting my
intelligence
yeah and that's what I'm afraid they're
gonna do is they're just gonna pass it
off and just say well I mean it's
different
like okay yeah sure like if you take 15
beach balls and you had them sitting
side-by-side yeah I guess it's a
different than having them just like
sitting in a square but they're still
next to each other so what does it
matter I mean that you know it's it's to
me it's interesting like yeah I'm
curious to see I mean we could be
entirely wrong they've just kind of said
well there's battle oh yeah some stuffs
gonna happen that's really all they said
like there's about a world and stuffs
gonna happen so much also really they're
all gonna fight anything why would I buy
it that if it's gonna not if it's gonna
give it away
you know I mean like don't give it away
balderdash you mean to tell me that
Marvel Comics made a bombastic
announcement and then didn't deliver on
that announcement that is flowing said
one thing but then did another I know
that one thing that they did did not
undercut the sales they would make from
such an announcement by the way right
now join us for the weekly pool
SuperDuper crazy announcement about an
event we're doing in six months on
Thursday at 4:00 p.m. we'll all be here
it's gonna be huge guys you have to
believe us every fight nothing will ever
be this way we'd never be the same you
know what's it just me or did anybody
else that watch the live stream look
like it was put together in like ten
minutes they were like you know they
should have said hold your applause
until we're [ __ ] cut because that
applause was like this if all three of
us clapped that is how many people were
at that stupid freakin event it was yeah
it was and they had like some clown oh
he made like the lamest like zingers
I've ever heard in my life like these
humorless ass clowns are up there trying
to like give us the press
and they're like so let's look at this
screen and her and like do I get anybody
who knows what they're doing to present
your material it's almost like they
don't know how to present their stories
to people and so they have these like
you have people who can actually make
videos who make those the presentations
weird guys for the room you know we are
gonna have a secret convergence yeah
let's do team a 2016 we're gonna
converge all of our channels into one
massive channel it will be called TV
little comic explain Marvel Marvel
explains story in house but I don't know
it was funny watching it because I was
like oh my god like this I mean this
looks like it looks like a high school
science fair project or something like
that there's like but like I thought I
thought like when they said well let's
show you guys like our trailer like they
just zoomed in on TV I was like I
thought they were just gonna like bring
it up on the we have on our channels
which you could watch at any point yeah
that they had out for months and months
and months it looks all the way up if
you want to find do if you want to watch
the trailer the most the best quality
one coming story is comic story it's
just the problem is with common story
ends is that somewhere in it a giant
dick appears so if your opponent doesn't
like it all cares about your kids you
probably shouldn't like go see that I
put I put the giant dick in there to
prevent copyright so just violate the
hell out of the Terms of Service and
just avoid you know whatever see people
are making up names now a little house
or mother story in a little house comic
explains god man this is why I love this
is why I love our fans because they go
through and just make these crazy
they've got they've got lost in the
incursion he became comicdrake
what yeah you know what since you
brought them up let's go ahead and Rob
where's common trick because somebody
decided not to tell other members of our
party it wasn't a deliberate thing it
was just the best of money it's like Rob
didn't call any of us we called he'd
call Rob and then her hubby's jumped in
late who's ever gonna live children like
I was I'm getting I'm getting the plugs
and the wires I changed them we're
having the brake pads and rotors change
in my car so I was II I had business
yeah I had like important things going
on unlike you guys who were apparently
just sitting around is waiting for me to
call I'm glad I don't know how much to
you guys I was I was actually making
another video we were talking before I
like when we were getting ready I'm like
thank God Rob is not here so I don't
know like it was to me it was funny
watching the whole presentation because
I just I could not get past that I was
like I mean they've got kind of like a
sheet like draped over something and
it's like half hanging off you know and
it's like it's like they were just like
whatever just go with just make the damn
announcement if it was gonna be
something that big I would have expected
they would have not necessarily like
just throwing money everywhere but they
spent a little more money than that
that's the thing that's my point about
the comic book industry like that was a
big presentation for them really like
they don't have disney money Disney will
pay to have them produce Star Wars books
but like they like when when Marvel's
like we're gonna do a big we're gonna
tell people about the big event Disney
if they had any say in it whatsoever
which they probably didn't was probably
like go for it have you been like well
though I've been to Marvel corporate
I've seen their offices it's a lovely
building with lots of neat stuff
wouldn't it have been cool for them to
do it from the goddamn booth no to
Midtown comics and then go set it up in
their freakin store like it like my show
like go to the store put up your cameras
and sit in front of it and shoot your
show like let's not have a stupid
corporation that is publicly traded
should operate it was it was it here's
my question you know here's my question
for you though and is this is the big
question
who planned that what is that a golem
was that horrible
no no say what's that Marvel calling
Midtown or was that Midtown stating hey
do you guys have any kind of press
release coming up and would like to have
you on site
we'll handle everything probably and
then drop the ball on it so something
I've dealt with Marvel's with Marvel's
PR department and I've dealt with
Marvel's like interns the people who
like deal with like potential clients
and customers Aysen stuff like that and
they're just communications majors like
they don't know anything and they have
no idea how to like manage and like
swear to god I work with like Marvel and
I we we had a little back-and-forth ones
and they accidentally sent me there
behind my back correspondences Wow like
because I was on the freakin CC and they
were just like and I'm like and I
responded I'm like I'm sure you didn't
mean for me to get this email you should
probably get your [ __ ] in order and and
they were like whoops
they didn't say whoops but their
complete lack of a response was whoops
and like so clearly like they just had
like they were like they had an intern
or they don't because they can't afford
to have them in the building and they
were like whatever just set it up
I'm sure Midtown probably called them up
I'm sure I'm thinking was Midtown
calling and unless somebody's
responsiveness and they wanted to
capture the YouTube feel that's what
they were going for but but you know
what tells it was so poorly want to
capture the YouTube feel is like it was
so poorly set up they didn't even know
what they really wanted to talk about
like like they're just so do you guys
want to reveal some stuff on this and
they're just gonna it's it's the
battleworld and here's the whole first
issue and I mean dude it's it's it was
funny watching that video because I was
like you know what I just finished
watching a video by Vsauce where he was
explaining how black holes work it's one
man in a black shirt standing in front
of a black screen and it had a higher
production quality than the weekly poll
want to do this
and it would have been better look at
this like we have like we've cameras and
and different people's perspectives and
everyone knows how to talk and modulate
their voices like come on guys
like how beastly would that have been if
Marvel was like hey the weekly pool do
you guys want to do like the signature
like you know we would've done we would
have done it for free because they
wouldn't have even had to pay for the
subway ticket everyone get it just got
on skype freaking me and you know we
would have done I would have water side
we would have worked it out with the
other guys with like we're like guest
appearance like Bendis jumps on the
stream and like hickman pops in for a
few minutes you know I mean like an
encouraging Jonathan bindus right oh my
god worst idea ever somebody out there
in the chat if you guys are good with
Photoshop I want to see Jonathan Hickman
like it was gonna happen somebody's
gonna have like paint and they're just
gonna like cut a circle around our heads
and they're just going to show like all
three heads just like hitting each other
okay that was actually pretty fun
for those of you guys who know those of
you guys who didn't see like any of the
behind the scenes footage over at Sal's
channel for the whole back issues thing
and we were all at New York Comic Con
that was the most fun I ever had in my
life that was so fun like recording back
you'll see I think it's called
crossovers it's in the back it's in back
issues I mean I thought like no one
could stop laughing
like you know it was really trying to be
the biggest problem with that and we got
to go back to Secret Wars guys but
bigger someone that was trying to get
everyone on camera like you couldn't go
far to Mecca
it was insane but we want to do the
youtubers centipede if we all get
stapled together to be a human centipede
I'm really in the front I'm calling it
out Oh
Taco Bell Rob's the B then no [ __ ] bed
I'll just shoot myself in the face and
just not have to worry about it we've
got battleworld set up so like
battleworld is a mess and who the hell
knows the other thing they said I guess
what do we want to talk about night like
with with respect to that like we could
talk about the different worlds they're
gonna do a question I was gonna have say
we know they told us what the most
popular ones are going to be like the
name drum there's huge lists yeah yeah
but I mean like I've been looking for it
oh yeah there's a huge list that I had
pulled up right yeah but um secret
anyone's battleworld
there was here is this one's like 7,000
yeah at the battle right now I don't
I got you bro I got you bro here we go
the battle world is
and III told you man this could be a
total catastrophe like but but well yes
we know it's like we know like the
stories like Age of Apocalypse we know
that like future Emperor I don't know
why they're doing future imperfect but
they do we feature imperfect the armor
wars I don't know why they're doing
those things but those are like I guess
big stories and stuff like that they
reveal that to us what I want to know
are like the smaller ones like what
smaller stories are going to be in here
what stories did we are we just not
thinking of that are gonna be there I
mean spider-gwen is it in there I'm
telling you it's gonna be in there I
feel like there's news and or so I guess
here's the list of everyone cuz we've
been going over it's just up for the
sake of the thing okay and I think you'd
like me a different one soon is that
yeah that's the map that doesn't give
you everything although this is a spider
land on that map I think it was either
spider lander Spider Island no spider at
the spider land Oh which one do you guys
have because this article has it at the
bottom alright so we're gonna have
Planet Hulk X been 92 age of the
apocalypse or Age of Apocalypse of a
part of the apocalypse my god amazing
spider-man renew your vows which has
shown him to be married with Lady Parker
again here's a Future Passed Sentinel
territories the regice
Regency the Regency yeah the reason is a
tiller of rising Attila we all took a
universe both of them till it rising
okay so in humans they get your
Imperfects House of M Avengers vs. x-men
I guess they just never stopped fighting
I don't know how it works but right
don't with man's load meet Civil War age
of Ultron vs. the marble zombies
although that's one world in itself or
or one well here's another thing we have
to consider too this is some I don't
think about until its second ago and in
the incursion storyline if you remember
when you jump to earth four million when
you have DC basically those characters
came about due to the anti heroic age
the heroic age that was a result of all
the normal earthbound superheroes being
killed off I like like Wolverine like
The Avengers the x-men the Fantastic
Four although scared like all of them
basically models the entire current
lineup
died and then that new generation of
superheroes came in and then they
uttered in like the age of science or
whatever whatever it is like the great
age they were great scientific a jury
but anyway the fact remains that all
those events took place it's just this
future was basically this reality was in
a like basically further along the
timeline than the current reality is and
so what I'm thinking here is that in
these realities the age of Ultron
happened and these realities or I guess
the catalyst for the age of Ultron
happened but they never stopped Ultron
right like Ultron was never defeated and
one reality we know that the Age of
Apocalypse came to an end because
Apocalypse was was killed by magneto and
the reality was or that I guess that the
United States North America was
destroyed with nuclear missiles from you
know Europe but it could be that in this
reality of Age of Apocalypse that never
happened
that magneto never killed apocalypse
whatever it is it took place Bishop
never told magneto what what's going on
they never went to search for the
uncrown crystal and so on and so forth
it could be that in these realities
things just played out totally different
that the cathode had caused these
realities took place but the realities
kept on their normal current had nothing
happened to stop that reality from
coming to an end you know I mean
basically if the good guys number one
right I always thought here's my thought
when they first announced this thing I
really thought that what they were doing
was that worse they were saying these
are the events that happened but
apparently it's gonna be something even
more ridiculous where not only do they
happen but they're gonna keep happening
I don't I don't know like either way
what I was hoping for and in truth I
think this would've been the smart move
by Marvel I was hoping they would have
just rebooted everything
if Marvel had gone back to the drawing
board and said you know what who cares
that people think we're basically
copying DC whatever this never they
should not just like wipe the slate
clean and said this is your zero this is
this is 1960-something all over again
and this is Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
creating characters and this is what
we're doing so they they go from there
and decide how everything needs to be
done and what that would do is basically
allow them to tie the characters from
the from this from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe more
closely into the characters of their
making as they create them in the Marvel
Universe they can decide what kind of
Tony's luck they want to have now do
they want to have the superior Iron Man
or they want to have the traditional
Iron Man
I like superior Iron Man better I'd like
the [ __ ] Tony Stark who doesn't care
yeah I mean it's kind of fun he's more
fun he's more he creates more problems
but like then again I'm not the hugest
Iron Man fan like I like the movie Iron
Man but like I never like I've read the
books but I'm like these sort of like
like I don't like them like so I would
be happy to see a reboot but I could
imagine some Iron Man fans being like it
would be like me saying like yeah you
know what screw Spider Man make him make
a Miles Morales I don't care I'd be like
ah realize oh yeah just rook quicker
they said this since the the lights have
gone down in the back that they wanted
to hear some Marvin Gaye we don'twe to
get a copyright shock on my channel
Minnie I appreciate it this is what guy
just keeps commenting on my lights have
gone down and he's like Oh either you
turn the lights on or our here's the
Marvin Gaye but ya know either way I
think it's what I don't think that's
where we are I mean like well we don't
know anything we just know that like we
know more than we certainly like we have
some confirmation on some stuff like we
know that like it's kind it's I guess
it's like a soft reboot yeah yeah it's
basically okay so from what we've
gathered I mean we can we can speculate
all day long that's the thing like yes
most DC and Marvel look like they're
basically going to do yet another sort
of reboot run off I don't think that
they're gonna be full-on reboots like
the Marvel ones suppose is gonna merge
with the Ultimate Universe and by the
end they're gonna do what they want to
do with that so we're probably gonna
have a lot of things still in continuity
but the question is gonna be what yeah
it's gonna be probably like hell the new
52 started where we're gonna get all
this stuff and we're gonna be like well
what happened in Marvel is gonna be like
oh no
on the flipside DC is doing the same is
that crap I mean if you go through their
publication of what's coming up for
conversions it's like Wally West when
the pre new 52 is going through and this
university Berman's marriage to Lois
Lane and this universe Batman is stupid
crap Batman is exactly as he is that's
what I'm that's what I'm kind of
irritated about I wanted like I was
hoping that with this whole event it was
gonna be this planned out thing I have
no doubt that Marvel planned it out but
here was a Marvel did Marvel said in 3
or 4 years we want to do this great big
huge event and they said Jonathan
Hickman make it happen so he was like
okay and like increase in they said that
he was he pitched it I still don't think
they were fully onboard of it because
the incursians feels too stretched out
to be completely planned like I'm
thinking I here's what I'm thinking I
mean I'm this is me just spitballing
here but I think Donna think we said I
wanted to be incursions and if you guys
wanted you guys actually want to reboot
Marvel because that's been in talks
forever now you know um if you guys
really want to reboot marble this is a
perfect opportunity and Marvel's like
how about we start the incursion to see
how's that plans out you know and he was
getting near the end of it he was
wrapping it up in infinity and they were
like you know what that's a great idea
let's spend the next year prepping for
that yeah everything just dragged out
and turned into what it is now but see
I'm good I was gonna say they just that
they openly admitted that they were that
they did drag it out they didn't say it
like that but like I mean they say oh
they didn't yeah it feels like we've
been planning this and or we've that
we've basically been like having this
going on so it's like age of Ultron yeah
but Rob you and I could go I could very
easily tell you right now I've been
planning this episode of the weekly poll
for the last five years okay I'm sure
you don't know if that's accurate or not
do you really think Marvel will make a
press release and they say actually we
just started playing this last week and
we threw some stuff at the wall this
needs to be working or do you think it
sounds better if they're like but no
we've been playing in this since the
fair the whole thing is the plans are
this wait a minute I'm sorry I'm looking
at this map of battleworld
and the countries are like how cells
like I've been looking at this map
I'll get really close I'll get really
close let's map here titles it's not all
the titles these are actually like
realms 99 is a realm you know you know
what this looks like you know it looks
exactly like this mat looks like the map
from old man Logan yes it does that's
exactly what it looks exactly what I
thought as soon as I saw it I was like
that looks like the map from old man
Logan this is gonna be like the world
like I don't know it feels like people
are just gonna like I feel like it's
gonna look like old man Logan we're like
people are like factions are gonna be
formed and teams are gonna come together
and they're gonna go broke they're gonna
walk from like $2.99 to like Valley of
the flame and like they'll have to cross
mutopia to get there by the way mutopia
is my joke that I made about utopia back
in the House of M episode link in the
description box down below like and
subscribe we'll see you next time that
was a great one um no I you might you
marry right here it may just be that
like all these realities just converged
on a one planet and they all just starts
taking stuff out and they're like this
is our territory nobody come over here I
don't know that may very well be the
case I mean it may just be that like all
these people are just like okay look
we're kind of the only ones left this is
like the last chunk of reality and none
of us want to die let's just stake out
parts of the planet and make it our own
here's it here's a really quick
speculation the the worlds like Age of
Apocalypse x-men 92 like spider-man
renew your vows those are all the
versions of the characters that are left
and so the only survivors of that on
battle world will be the ones who are
left in the new Marvel continuity so
like eczema 92 the rogue character from
92 the cool one that could fly and it's
awesome complain what is the one that
stays spider like Spider Man who's
married though what's the one people
want or like they've you know they've
done market research and decided like oh
it turns out young Spider Man doesn't
matter like man
Age of Apocalypse like blink survives
and so she's part of the new continuity
like that was how they just pick and
choose characters from all these
different worlds and realities that you
want to see and they could like pretend
like some of them died but then like
bring them back later and be like oh you
survived the battle world thing like
look at that like if you thought it was
gonna be convoluted em just trying to
merge six one six in that and ultimate I
try bagent taking word is gonna pick and
choose the best parts of everything if
they have a master list already
I like I would go I would be on board
for that I I will say this though if
they do that they need to release that
master list at the end of the event
instead of doing the new 52 method of
will figure it out as we go
no yeah we need to know like the moment
this ends who survived and who we're
looking for ya know they have a list I
think I think have a list of who
survived who is dead and who died like
wow yeah like the the MIAA died yeah but
like here's here's the big question
though
like how much planning if any did they
do in this long-term or did they just
say okay look if Jonathan Hickman once
says that we should probably reboot
everything maybe we should not I'll
think of so much they thought that
Jonathan Hickman knows better than them
I think that they said okay fine and
maybe Hickman can make a compelling case
maybe you said hey look like number ones
do good with model now you've got
characters now that everybody hates no
one cares about you're gonna cancel the
Fantastic Four anyway so it's not like
I'm gonna go back to Future Foundation
I mean Future Foundation all that stuff
is gonna end so I think you said look
just just do some variation of a reboot
and so Marvel said okay and they said
we'll do like this Secret Wars thing
which I don't know why they're calling
it Secret Wars if the beyonders not
there it's because it's like that and
they're taking patchworks of everything
and everyone's gonna fight so it's just
like cigarettes plus you like it and
remember it right so maybe you'll come
on board both riding the stars all the
way down okay but in any event the idea
here is this it's somewhere along the
line they stopped planning
and they said let's just yeah if they
planned it all if they said they just
said let's play about here let's see
what happens and so I'm sure they have
issues one through a planned out and
here's what we're gonna do and here's I
think actually said those issues are
completed and so they said here's what's
gonna happen like here's here's what's
done here like and then after those
issues one through eight then it's just
whatever happens happens and by the way
they should do that like no delays
what do you mean like no delays on like
the actual event like you can't be a
month late like you gotta this gotta be
done oh yeah yeah I agree sorry I like
original sin where it was still coming
out after original sin was over and
during access yeah they were releasing
like original sin tie-ins visible sale
or forever evil that was supposed to end
in like February and I think it's
dressed up in like many uh-huh well we
did you know summer event we didn't even
find out what Captain America like what
the sin was or what did there's a
Captain America found out when he found
out about the incursions we didn't find
out about that no original sin when you
find out that find out about that and
tilling Avengers until he's into like it
was Avengers he's like hey I'm gonna
travel in the future and try to find the
time Jim okay whatever but whatever yeah
it was a cool it was I'm really hoping
this is gonna be a lot better because
they've chosen great stories to throw
into this battle world I mean they're
all like iconic stories of Marvel Comics
purpose obvious I don't know but it's
just but what I'm hoping is that the
suspense or that the result will live up
to the suspense that's what I'm hoping
that what's it like that the Marvel
ending when we sat down and it really
said okay look guys let's actually like
go balls to the wall this time let's
actually make this something worth
reading and they weren't just kind of
like hey guys what happens when the
incredible hope gets angry and he's
kicked off on earth and did he comes
back it's like well he makes the
Illuminati fight each other
okay and then Robert Reynolds beats him
to a standstill and they turned they
turned back into their human forms okay
whatever like that was that was what
we're hoping a nutshell
I'm hoping this becomes better than that
I'm hoping this is really Marvel
swinging for the fences and producing
something awesome will it be that way I
doubt
here's my theory here's my I'm gonna end
this disco cuz we're kind of we're kinda
just run in circles now so I'm gonna
throw this last theory out there all the
universes are gonna fight there and all
of the key characters are going to die
in the new lead of the Marvel Universe
the person in charge that they put on
all the books Squirrel Girl dude if they
do that if okay if that happens if mom
does that I'm so okay this match of
yours I hope he does know he's just now
imagine Jasper thingsit's now like he's
alive now after the House of M I
guarantee you that is probably not what
we were doing this alright that's about
the know when they're asked with the
weekly pulled that net and I want to
clarify we're gonna launch that January
first guys um the response of you guys
has been incredible so what we decided
to do was the setup because the original
is just gonna launch any first it's kind
of like a we'll put it out and see what
happens and if it does well we'll retool
it but since you guys are you excited so
excited about it the responses we got we
sat down and we viously retooled the
idea early and we're pushing it for our
February 1st launch and so we're trying
to aim for it might still get push back
a little more so we're trying to put out
the big project now instead of retooling
it later while it's live so yeah that's
that's why I'd get held up and we have
it said much I think next week we're
gonna have nerdsync on the show Rob
that's the plan
yep we're gonna have got a single here
on Tuesday yeah next episode and we are
still planning out various interviews
and I guess we should close this out
like we always do what does everyone do
I gather channel I'm finishing up the
house of M here in the next next little
bit or so I guess the next few days or
several days or whatever and then on a
DC explained I have
The Killing Joke going on so and I love
The Killing Joke that is such a good
story I love that story you should do
you should check out fat man on Batman
the Kevin Smith podcast we talks to
Grant Morrison about The Killing Joke
low your mind I'm not gonna ruin
anything chat keep your mouth shut
there's no authority on this stupid book
it's just a really cool interpretation
there's a stupid interpretation no no
it's not it's stupid it's awesome stupid
I'm a bigger Batman fan than Vinny and
I'm telling you it's awesome no you're
not all right what are you doing Santi
Phil applause we can do this
we are doing the new episode of hack and
splash page from Tiffany just launched
today we're doing witches so you can
check that out on the Channel TV little
house calm or youtube.com slash teeny
little house we have a new off-the-rack
that launched we all knew off-the-rack
launched last week where we do all three
books instead of splitting them up into
three different episodes we did Squirrel
Girl last week so that launched the
second iteration or the second episode
of off the rack
all new off the rack launched yesterday
and Thursday we'll be doing back issues
as always where we reviewed one of the
books behind me and then we're gonna do
letters page on Friday where we read
your comments and the winner of the one
we decide is the best comment gets a
sign post card and or in the future
we're gonna have way better prizes so
you know check it out
and I overhead a comic story in this
week and next week we've been doing a
whole bunch of in last week we've been
doing Lantern origins as we prepare to
tell the stories of the lanterns the
green ladder brightest day one of the
lanterns rising the Third Army first
Lantern and then the end as they call it
do all of those stories I just put out
the flash episode just before this so if
you want to go get caught up in the new
52 reverse flash that's his story and
we're also gonna be doing things like
miss Marvel I'm prepping Civil War we're
doing things like that I'm doing this
Marvel cuz no one else seems to want to
just oh it's a good idea miss Marvel
great character and I just didn't know
how to pronounce her name
camel makan come on come on look on I
think it's Kamala Khan come on
I'll say that comments who had
me or him I really need to know all
those who say the thing it's gonna read
out loud
all right guys anybody want to say
anything on Rob's vaping so I guess
we're done signal that's like the chime
alright guys thanks for joining us this
week for the weekly poll we are back on
schedule and we will be here next
Tuesday and we'll be here every Tuesday
and if you guys pester Rob enough this
will start getting uploaded to iTunes
again cuz he's failing also next week
comicdrake may or may not join us I
don't know depends if Rob decides to
call so look forward to that yeah and
nerdsync and its super effective
eventually oh yeah that'd be cool don't
we need alright peace out guys later